do you wish your daughter was dating a
chubby old polygraph guy yes alright you
good today I'm gonna be doing a
lie-detector test on my stepmom I'm kind
of nervous but I think it's gonna be
funny I'm most excited to know and she's
really a rebel we'll see I'm honest with
my son honestly I have no idea to find
honest we do share some deep secrets I
consider my mother my best friend
sometimes I think we talk too much
because I feel like he forgets that I'm
gonna parent ask me some questions well
that's what we're here to do today
father did you do track in high school
mmm-hmm we both did track that's so cool
I thought you're just saying that to
like make me like like you more do you
wish I would dress more feminine no it's
a lie
I do like dressing more masculine or
feminine I know that he's Kenny your
real name
yes true was it your idea for my dad to
cut his hair or was it his literally he
has had long hair for like as long as I
can remember would you ever do an edible
with me yes
Kru you know what your dad is getting
older he said it first and I told him no
John will tell you she's having a
problem huh
so it was right it was prepping you to
be oh Messiah would you ever let me
shave my head see that's a lie what if I
want to shave my head and just wear wigs
all the time hey dad do you have a
favorite son no that's a lie is it me
yes that's a truth don't show this to
your brother did you really meet my dad
at the grocery store
or was it the booze cruise did I meet
him on the booze cruise no come on I
knew it I don't think this works dead
yeah do you think I'll ever find love
yes not true come on
[Music]
do you think I'll ever find lust mother
would you ever use a vibrator yes true
let's go shop for wood did you have
sexual relations before the age of 18
no true Oh dad I'm a nerd what do you
want from me
was I an accident no my dog at that time
that you came over to my biological
mom's house wasn't it really awkward or
was that just me we actually met before
you thought we met yes it was awkward
telling the truth have you and mom ever
done anything while I was in the house
no solo Oh be more specific
oh [ __ ] I don't want to be more specific
would you ever let me bring over a girl
yes cool cool because I'm actually
talking to one right now there you go
she's one have you ever had an affair no
[Music]
true let's go it's all I need in here
I'm out of here where we go where we go
we just took our lie detector tests and
we found out that my father here's a
loyal husband and that I'm his favorite
son so I think it's been a great day I
know my mom wore now and she's still
beautiful as she is I'm glad I got this
off my chest I'm tired of just holding
it in what about the booze curse oh yeah
I don't want to tell you that part
[Music]